samantha is in houston texas to kick
this hour off
hi samantha how are you hi
i'm fine how are you guys great how can
we help
oh so quick question um i've been
listening to you
since january and i've been serious
since february but i've been serious by
myself
my husband i've been trying to get him
on board and he's just not having it
he's not he's he's not wanting to budget
like with the gazelle intensity yeah
like me
he just wants to kind of budget and i
want to 100
budget and be really strict um i don't
want to make him feel like i don't honor
him as my husband and
i don't want to make him feel like i
don't want to work as a team
so did you did you sit down and do a
budget together and you ran him off by
being strict
i think that may have been what happened
okay give me an example of a category he
thought you were cray cray on
um eating out for example how much did
you have for eating out
i had maybe 50 bucks
because i know he likes to eat out for
lunch he doesn't like to take lunch with
him
what's your household income um about 6
500 monthly
and how much debt do you guys have oh
a hundred and eighty two thousand
dollars on what
most of it is um his student loans
that's around 133 000
my car around 5 500 on his car
of both of our credit cards that's
pretty much what all of our debt is
outside of the house we've got a lot of
debt but you have a pretty good income
rachel what would you do well i'm
curious what does he do what did he do
with that degree
pardon what did he do what what's he do
for a living
oh um he works for the city he manages a
health clinic
for the city of houston okay cool yeah
well this is always tough getting
another spouse on board is a question i
feel like we get
all the time and i kind of have like a
three prong approach that i do so like
number one is your why
so sitting down and not you know not
barking at them about the budget no
you're not doing this i want you to do
this all that's
explaining your why like what is your
why samantha is it because you're
stressed out is it because you're
fearful if something happens you don't
know how you guys are going to be
financially
is it because you want to be able to
live with the thought of like no
payments and the freedom that comes with
that are you doing it for your kids like
like figure out your why and his
and sit down and have that conversation
though and explain it to him like this
is what's going on in me
this is why i want to do it it's more
than just 50 of going out to eat a month
like i don't you know you probably don't
even want that either
like but i'm i want to do these
sacrifices in order to get out of debt
so that
x and fill in that blank and have that
conversation and get his
take as well so start with like the
bigger picture kind of the more
emotional side
and then get tactical so especially for
men i find that if you can do progress
show visual progress they're more up to
do the plan
so you just saying hey we're gonna do 50
we're going out to eat
sorry like that's how it's going to be
he's probably oh no i don't want to do
that i don't want to do that
but if you say hey you only have we if
we choose to do this
it's only going to be x amount of months
that that this is how our life is going
to be it's not forever
we're not going to do this for 15 years
maybe it's 15 months or like you do the
math and figure out
this is how long it will take to get out
of debt if we budget like this
and sometimes i'm just seeing that
progress they're like okay because
there's hope on the other end
because he's probably feeling like you
just took all the fun money and now
i can't do anything i can't have fun
because you just want to get out of debt
and it just sounds miserable
but showing the progress i think is is
huge and then
lastly samantha i would say if those
don't work bring in a third party so
whether that's
one of our books maybe that's the
podcast maybe it's a marriage counselor
like i don't know what it is
but bringing in that third party for you
guys i think can be extremely extremely
helpful
yeah so samantha you also have children
yes we have two children 16 and 10. okay
let me give you an illustration that's
not going to happen
but it but it gets your attention
emotionally okay
um right now it's like his mommy
is saying he can't have money to go out
to eat
you're not being his wife you're being
his mommy that's how this conversation
feels
he doesn't want that and you don't want
to be that
okay yeah if instead you did what
rachel's talking about and you both had
a really big
reason then he would
be on board to make the decision with
you and
you know the example i'm going to use is
not going to happen but if one of your
children were ill
and you had to save 20 000 really really
fast
to save their life he wouldn't be
bitching about going out to eat
yeah because you'd have a big enough why
he doesn't have a big enough why and so
he's not willing to sacrifice the now
for the later because he doesn't believe
the later
it's not worth it it's not worth it and
so that turns you into the nagging wife
or the mommy
and turns him into the little boy or the
husband whose wife is listening to some
crazy butt guy on the radio and messed
her up
right and i turned me into a cuss word
right
and so yes yeah so i i think you guys
back up
and if you get it if you go if you start
talking about what hogan says to
dream in high definition dreaming hd
and quit talking about fifty dollars
going out to dinner the fifty dollars
going out to dinner will solve itself
when you both have a big enough
reason to do this and by the way you do
if you're looking at this and you have a
hundred and eighty two thousand dollars
worth of debt
and it doesn't scare the crap out of you
you're not really dialed in
which translation he ain't dialed in
this should scare him
enough to go as a man as a husband
as a person i don't want this thing
hanging over my head
and it's like he should have an oh crap
moment
you know but he hasn't yet he hasn't yet
and when he does it'll change everything
so i think you back up and quit using me
as a stick to beat him quit using the
budget to try to control him
he'll do all this stuff faster than
you'll do it once he has a reason
as if your child were ill and you had to
come up with twenty thousand dollars
if you can get that in his head and go
if we do this for a short period of time
we can save this family's life we can
get out of 182 000
worth of debt because you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
you make more than that uh you're coming
home with 6 500 you said right so yeah
you're probably making 120 a year and um
so you know you can say we make too much
money to be this broke
we're not ever going to be anywhere
we're stuck we got to get out of this
the house is on fire
run for the door and you don't have to
ask somebody to run for the door when
the house is on fire they run
and so you don't have to ask somebody
save money for their out of their lunch
money to save their child's life if
their child needs saving
you know they do it there's not a human
on the planet wouldn't give up their
lunch money to save their child
of course they would so all that
illustrates is not that your child's ill
or something like that
but all that illustrates is that if you
have a big enough why
you everyone is willing to sacrifice to
get to it
good good question you're going to do
fine hold on i'm going to put the put
you guys through
ramsey plus for a one year subscription
put the whole family in financial peace
university
get him going through the class with you
it's going to change everything